i think the ice cream helps uh alleviate
a lot of the heat that's hot
this is spicy ice cream right here
[Music]
hey guys it's mike chan welcome back to
kong has the sweetest
coolest show on the internet now fire
and eyes are really polar opposites of
each other but
what if you combine these two forces of
nature into
one incredibly delicious icy
treat now you've seen me pour hot oil on
my ice cream some day before but today
it's all about finding that perfect
balance the ultimate pairing
between heat and sweet the best person i
can think of to join me
the host of the hottest show on the
internet hot ones
mr sean evans how you doing buddy hey
mikey thanks so much for having me i'm
doing great honored that you'd include
me on this spicy journey of yours
you utilize a lot of spice in your life
and that's an understatement
and i know that when you were with uh
vsauce you used
ice cream sundae as an antidote for the
last dab now
how do you feel about spice and sweet
going together i think i'm just curious
i mean i've eaten so many spicy dishes
over the years but i don't think i've
ever had a spicy ice cream
so i'm just like curious how this whole
thing's gonna turn out
it might be a game changer you know hot
sauce when paired with certain meals can
elevate them so much so if it can do the
same thing with ice cream
make ice cream which is already amazing
even better that i'm down hopefully
we're breaking new ground today
spicy ice cream is not just a gimmick
anymore there's so many makers out there
really pushing the boundaries
of combining chilies and icy treats uh
you ready to go dude
let's go baby
all right first off sean we have hot
scream this is a company out of
connecticut
so this happened when a couple friends
were sitting around watching football
and they were eating buffalo wings
and i guess that got a little spicy so
they try to kill the spice with some ice
cream
and then they dump their wing sauce into
the ice cream
and that's how hot scream came about he
got strawberry
salted caramel chocolate and espresso
which one you want to do first let's
start with the salted caramel swirl
you ready buddy cheers
so initially i think it's just good ice
cream like when you try it for the first
time
it's not like you get hit with spice but
then once it goes down it kind of
leaves a chemtrail of spice around my
mouth i can really feel that chili
even the caramel there's chilies in that
as well
and it hits you like kind of the back of
your tongue
and like you said it just tastes like
it's really creamy it's good ice cream
you want it to keep
taking another spoonful but after about
like
five seconds and your mouth starts
tingling
i like that feeling and then on top of
it though it has like the inverse
relationship that you'd expect with ice
cream so
on the show sometimes somebody will eat
something really spicy and then
they'll ask for ice cream or they'll
chase it with ice cream but they're
doing that because
they're trying to fight that feeling
that spice in their mouth
this is the opposite now we're stuck in
this spiral we're like a dog chasing its
own tail because
there's nothing to chase this out all we
can do is add to the fire
all we can do is make it hotter with
this table it's kind of diabolical this
ice cream
let's go with this chocolate swirl
that's delicious i guess this is the
thing that i'm wondering right
now does ice cream need to be spicy you
know this ice cream is just
so good as is do you find that the heat
is an annoying byproduct of that or do
you think it's elevating
whatever we're eating right now if you
just give me these ice creams on its own
without any chilies or anything like
that
i'm good with it like i like it it
tastes good it's creamy it's got a nice
flavor
the overall general tastiness of it is
through the roof
but with a little bit of heat it brings
up that addictive factor where you kind
of keep wanting to dig
in it's funny that you bring up
addiction because that's what i think
this is for
like chili heads that just need their
spice fix
because otherwise i don't know why you'd
mess with ice cream you know
hot scream who would have thought are
you ready for the next round
let's go
[Music]
sean really excited about this next one
i got in front of me and you as well
beautifully colored popsicles these are
paletas and we got them from
love new york in manhattan these are
mexican popsicles and usually you put
some of this stuff on top of it i never
had this before this is taking this
chili lime seasoning and to kind of
explain
more about this and this we have from
the crazy
gorilla youtube channel ramon guzman
thanks for joining us man
thanks for having me it's my pleasure
whenever you feature
politis and uh tahin people go crazy
over it what is so special about this
they're popsicles for people that don't
know but what does make them different
is they're water and milk based so
they're made with fresh fruit and then
you could also add condensed
milk to make it creamy a little sweeter
and they're each
handmade it's part of the culture it's
tasty and it's for everyone
which one you want to start with uh
let's go with this one
i see some chilies on here is that why
you picked it but what am i smelling
that's like mango
or something oh yeah this is definitely
chili mango
chili mango the cool thing about paletas
since they're made with like
fresh fruit usually you make them with
fresh
local fruits in the coastal regions they
have like pineapple
the northern areas they have mangoes and
stuff so each little area has their own
specific
local fresh fruit cheers everybody
cheers
oh this is like the love of my life that
i never knew existed
it's making me feel different things i
never felt before i think this is more
spicy than the ice cream we had
the spice on it is pretty profound like
you can really
feel that heat it's not for beginners
really
this is like like almost unexplainably
good
again it's like ramon said you're
tasting a lot of love here
what i do like about this one i like the
spice i like the chunks
the flavor is nice and intense to me it
feels like a little vacation in my mouth
all right i see sean has picked up the
most vibrant one of the group
this is uh the colors of the mexican
flag and cheers got cheers
cheers oh wow
oh watermelon this one's good
what do we do with this can we add this
to this oh of course
if you want to eat it like this
perfectly fine but if you want to make
it a little
more intense and a little more fun add
some tucking i like fun
i mean is this normal so i don't want to
be doing something that like
this is a blasphemous act towards uh
toledo
no it's it's perfectly normal tajin is
perfect for fruit
as far as i know paletas are made of
fruit so we're good to go
see this i like like a spicy pina colada
on vacation sort of situation here once
you get to the white
all right finally we have chamayata
and uh i had this in mexico ramon how do
you feel about this is this something
you like
oh this is something i really like it's
a nice little mango puree
mixed in with some chamoy sauce chamoy
is pretty much
a sauce made with fruits different
chilies and salt
similar to tajin but it's just in a
sauce form
so and then you have tajin on top of
that so you mix that in
you got the sweet you got some spiciness
i truly enjoy this i love experiencing
foods and desserts and ice creams from
different cultures and this
has been truly refreshing so thanks so
much ramon for joining us and giving us
some
amazing insight into this thanks for the
crash course ramon
anytime anytime y'all need me i'm here
[Music]
hey sean final round and this is riding
your wheelhouse now
i can't let you go without pairing some
ice cream
with hot sauces and we got a special
delivery from your friend noah over at
heatness and he sent us some
hot sauces that he says goes really good
with ice cream ready to give this a try
yeah i'm ready to give it a try first
off we have tamale pika
this is a mexican hot sauce with a smoky
flavor
with a corn oil base you ready let's do
it
oh looks like hot oil
very smoky we've had this on the show
uh tamale pika i think it was in the two
spot and it is a pretty spicy too
i'll save it maybe for like my final
verdict on this whole thing
but i feel like it's made this ice cream
taste like a chicken wing
like it needs to be on meat and not on
dairy
this is ice cream this is like the best
dessert that there
is it's such a special treat ice cream i
don't think we should be playing god and
messing with it
pouring hot sauce all over it we're
putting our foot through a picasso here
[Music]
next up we have heartbeat pineapple
habanero so it's sweet pineapple
with a hint of maltiness from ipa all
right again
squeeze bottle technology this is
another sauce that we had on hot ones
squeeze bottle makes for a nice ice
cream decoration like look at that look
how good that looks
how good does it taste though
i taste the pineapple but there's also a
lot more savoriness to the sauce
what this reminds me of is one time we
made these donuts
everything about it was like a donut but
then we'd have like these
crispy chicken skins and stuff inside of
the donut to make like a hot winged
donut
it had hot sauce in it and everything
this kind of tastes
like that donut for better or worse
finally we have wilshere scorpion yeah
this is very very spicy but i heard it's
also a little sweet
well this sauce i've had plenty of times
we had it on the show while back
and i'll say the difference between this
sauce and these sauces is that this
one's really really hot like
these are sort of like first or second
level sauces that we had on the show i
think this one right here was a back
half sauce maybe a seven
will sure chili farm does it improve ice
cream
[Music]
be careful with this one mikey there's
no going back
so far not too bad i think the ice cream
helps uh
alleviate a lot of the heat
that's hot this is spicy ice cream right
here
ah no that's spicy here let me give you
my closing thoughts
go ahead this was an intense pairing
if you want to just do something crazy i
don't know you're bored or something
then yeah put like the hottest hot sauce
in the world on your ice cream
this is a unique dining experience for
sure but here's what i'll say
you know if you ever go to an ice cream
store and you're getting toppings they
have
sprinkles so they have chocolate chips
you know what you never
ever see is hot sauce no one
ever puts hot sauce on their ice cream
and i think for good reason
if i've learned anything from this
experience and i was very happy to go on
the journey with you
but if i've learned anything from this
experience it's that i think there needs
to be
some distance between desserts and chili
peppers
i think that it's good that there's a
little bit of a buffer spicy and sweet i
feel like they do
go together if done correctly and today
a lot of it wasn't done correctly
but some of it was like the first round
i mean of all the stuff we ate today
what was your favorite the ice creams
were great up front
the paletas were great and then
i think that at the end here you know
putting the hot sauces on like it's some
sort of sundae
topping was to me a no-go
but like all things in life the journey
is fun
and uh spicy journeys especially i've
made a whole career out of it for crying
out loud
so thanks so much mikey for having me i
mean i really appreciate you hanging out
with me today
again wouldn't have wanted to share this
journey with anybody else and guys
hot ones season 12 is out now check it
out and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you